so Black Friday just two days away so
here are the best deals for gaming
laptops are going on right now are going
to be coming up on Black Friday starting
at the very entry level we have the HP
Pavilion in 15.6 inch II gaming laptop
it is equipped with the Intel i5 8 300h
a gtx 1050 TI 8 gigabytes of ddr4 2600 I
heard rant and I've one terabyte hard
drive this is pretty much the cheapest
laptop you can get with a dedicated
graphics card at Walmart this usually
costs seven hundred and ninety nine
dollars but this Black Friday you can
get it for two hundred hours off at $599
but pretty much 25% off next up if you
go one level above that you get the asus
rog Strix 15.6 inch gaming laptop it
also has two intel i5 8200 h a gtx 1050
TI 8 gigabytes of ram at point 66
megahertz but however it's one terabyte
hard drives actually an asus HD and it
also has a 128 gigabyte SSD on top of
that it also has a 120 Hertz refresh
rate so those are pretty much the major
differences between the last laptop and
this one and this one is right now $270
off and usually cost one thousand and
forty dollars and right now you can pick
it up for seven hundred and seventy
bucks so it really comes down to how
much you value a higher refresh rate
screen and most importantly an SSD after
that you could take it one more level
higher into the mid-level section with
gtx 260 s you can get the msi GL 63 15.6
inch gaming laptop this laptop has an
intel i7 AGM 50h a gtx 1066 goodbye card
a one terabyte hard drive wah 128
gigabyte SSD and 16 gigabytes of ddr4
ram and 2666 megahertz so over the last
laptop on this one you get the GTX 1066
a bicarb over the gtx 1050 TI and you
get the i7 instead of the i5 this one
comes in at nine hundred and thirty
dollars with a solid 320 m discount
which usually costs 1,250 bucks
next up if you are looking for a high
mid level laptop then the asus rog Strix
car edition 17.3 inch gaming laptop may
be perfect for you
it also comes with the Intel I 78758
a gtx 1066 quebec card and 16 gigabytes
of ddr4 ram at 2060 66 megahertz however
it actually has a 128 gigabyte PCIe SSD
a 1 terabyte sshd a bigger screen and a
120 heard refresh rate with 3
millisecond response time this laptop
usually cost $1500 but you can get it
for $200 off at $1,250 next up if you're
looking for a high end laptop then the
msi GP 63 leopard 15.6 inch gaming
laptop may be something to consider this
laptop has the Intel i7 8 750 H and gtx
1070 a 128 gigabyte SSD a 1 terabyte
hard drive and 16 gigabytes of ddr4 ram
at 2686 what was the last laptop this
lappa has a smaller screen and doesn't
have the sshd however it also has the
gtx 970 over two gtx 1066 compact card
so it is a bit of a trade-off but the
price is very close as well at $1,300
usually this laptop cost $17 we can get
a 400 discount this Black Friday finally
if you want a topic line Xtreme laptop
then you can get started getting the msi
GTC Riis 17.3 inch gaming laptop it is
pretty much identical with the last
laptop however as the GTX 1080 over the
gtx 1070 and as larger screen of 17.3
inches this laptop has pretty much
everything from the gtx 1070 to an i7 to
a large SSD and it also has a really
really great discount as well usually it
costs $2,800 but right now is six are
dollars off plus a $300 rebate card so
pretty much getting nine her daughter's
off but you can get this laptop for
1,900 bucks which they really really
steep discount but overall that's pretty
much the best laptops I could find for
each level of gaming and I really think
that they're really good deals make sure
to comment down below any laptops that I
may have missed because that will just
benefit other people also I'm going to
be coming out with another video today
about the best pre-built available for
Black Friday so make sure to stay tuned
for that
also if you guys like figure to make
sure drop a like and consider
subscribing you freely receive more
videos just like this one but until then
I'm Hari I'll see you guys next
[Music]